[музика]
сенатор маккейн дяку з інтерв'ю дякую
вам завищуйте вище за кілька денний на
брати прибраного президента США дональда
трампа
кандидата відра з публікою сильно вуста
їх виборах ви як республіка знайти witu
lite та з обидва пари може там обидва чоловіки
я за лузер ла ла я виживу
ну я був у підібраній у себе в аризоні
свисну прямого на трампа стала для
психолога і на спаді вангую завжди до нього
успіху ми вугрі я багатий про це щось за
зовнішньої політики та політики у голові
bespeco
я batman ще ми брат та мама доля у
роботі над ними час тусується
національних bespeco
то поки я виражений команди трампу
якубян де брау генерал меттіс
генерал флін генерал келлі я знаю всіх
людей багатий уроки у я вітаю їх
кандидатури червона дасин не знаю що
безпосередньо збирається рубає і прибраний
президент свято офіс щастя фарба
на свій porsche та прес-конференції
пісня виборі у вину паршивець приховано ви
явно в щілинки брата кричать передвиборною
кампанії США була тут не російською
і хакером і я міста це яку йому ж but
i вид ви бачите на них американської
сторони his pants might be плавати я би
радою плутатися його знання дональд
трамп правильно за значну inci україну
займаються подібним
алло я рада ще вин викличе по і
дальність russian за хакерські атаки
адресою мені виу темним а я накажу
барбари
parades and the call цієї ж години трамп
каже що
симпатія яку путін віч у lada niva сапр
його а нині часток нової адміністрації що
Путін по вожатих і США на боготу Біляші
нижче раніше ще росія зламувати
американський комп'ютер не міражі
що ви думаєте сервоприводу адресу у ялиною
black death worm і я про себе думаю
Володимир Путін
вбився бандит і продукт кгб я cry
домагається в коростово ти буди qs
ситуацію на свою гордість я вже великого
3 президенті США буша клінтон а і обаму
Які вірила тисяч з путіним можна на лапу
дай ти ж ніс
а он і хвалила його на приклад джордж
буш сказав ще бен соляного чий путіну і
побачивши його душу, а за честь його бам і
sepam я тануть про кнопку про та
Завантаження видно since росію aleksey
ми розуміємо а хто такий путін нам треба
повернутися до концепції шосе
управління рейху на світ за допомогою
сили і динамо вояку розумі путін самого
сили
вин повинен відразу meter все на кшталт ogres
ще до інших крейн надлишку будуть
більшими нижче висновку ми всі бачили queen
руїну в україну я queen прибравши до своїх
рук крим із ніші
як російський бомбарду валянки бомбив
або carnival і по
використовують високоточна оружня не
заразні занепалому як росія по річці davis
cup Калінінград.
і в серці робот економічна слабка
краї на таксі нам час повернути до
концепції світ через силу випадково ми
будемо заради вироку з путіним проте
лише з позиції сили
повний фініш
нас місяць трамп cr-v я не знаю я точно
знаю що генерал меттіс з розуму я
думаючі генерали колітів лінз і
розуміють еасп одягаюся ще геть і матами
позитивний вплив на рішення абрамова
президента
ось я avalon персона які ваш вираз
вид прес-конференції енергією залишився
конфлікт між трампом і cnn вважала
компанію винного по ширині фейкових
потрібен як ваші загальний вираз
прес-конференції у крем ви ніби про
росію та хакерські атаки
персиковий mad about an account
я міг би довго процесори ти а я скажу
коротко
прибраний президент трамп повністю
змінивши стиль
американської політики за крима ще раз у
місто стане twitter я до основного за
особливо комунікації трамп статний
мобілізувати своїх супротивників і ось
наша
рейтинг його популярності жебрак
рейтинг будникова abra нового президента
але ж не історії США перед ступами на
пост
в американській політиці настало дюжини
над не годиною країни розколота я хотів
якби трамп став президентом
всіх американців на закладі але ж того
волоссю воловани на виборах за нього обидва
про to win успішний політик з краще
видно, а ви полетите травня значення кінсей
результат
на початку сич не група сина-то revit
демократичну чи то республіканську партію
представила проект нового поки що
санкт ще до Москви я quit купити на
російських акторською атакою трамп петр і
на ці санкції
usb вхід d0
повторюсь а я не знаю
алла у нас я кілька вилок влади закону
dodge а судів і ви канал ш і в сонаті
мета новий пакет санкцій проти
Володимир Путін Петрович у нас уже все
на менше 10 ціна тариф за думаю ми
зможемо а за проводить ці санкції
все випадково закласти вигляд бетсі фактори
у засіки вигляді путіна у президента буде
вибір на клас ти в цю опускав цієї
санкції ct тшуву ми на мага і масі
досягнуто побачити нас проби володимира
путіна пітер вати фундаментальну основу
демократії
а сам батько не й вільно вибори c можна
назвати ідею ризикового характеру
нібито там не було кольору вже серйозно
нібито путін вдалося змінити результат
виборі тут з мало б руні вина зливки
для підвалу їм демократії
[музика]
крім курсу та контенту за та а дошки
статі ви вже назвав цих людей з команди
трампа як можна його вигляд повідати йому за
національну бас пеку тим часом з ченці
пройшли чутки не кандидата на посаду бірж
сократа ряд США
kill орсона нібито качу це його заяви
винзу крима сказавши що Петро йому і акт
магнітського kill орсон виклик чого
анексія криму на законне з акт
агресії
вин також та й ви всі нібито бургер з
оператором
США зараз українських шляхів постачав би
до нього у зброї не для тата народження
ризикових днів на сході України з батьком південь
хейн суп friend
одягаємо тлумачити була брехня.
я подібним зовсім батьком і пунктами
особливо його стем ще української армії
потрібні обороні us броня до його по три
мені про ти танковий ракетний комплекс і
джо вален
детальніше оружня не тисячі обама видно
вся треба ти це було нерівно прохання
тисячі відважних українців заглянув і в
тиві не я б у раді тому що тіла сонце
сказав ваш плануємо шейда часу нас
подавалася ще один укол і всі види
по єдиному харчування про те що являючи собою
росія і. Путін весь до вас з кращим
сем за голом ми не на всі його ви слова
не і понравилася а поки я член і виріж
і в як я волосся ват йому за його
кандидатуру йому жив його звільнення рішення
Вища повстання момент на прикиньте
ману нову руку ви вигляд бачив і no es que
dar стиснувши з одної Європи ви було у
україні грузії краї на балці і ви
говорили про те, що США буду і чи треба
гарантом б спк цик районний червона дональд
трамп розкрито кого в нато і
за крима поставлю піцу міф необхідний
посилання на неї я ту з таким статутом нато
edition pro колективно вид паве дальний
сторінок до нього альянсу
коли нападу на одну з них я кобудо
ваша реакція я хочу трамп 7 тяпа кону
ось ці зуби в я зайняла
одягайся че люди живуть краще не пояснювати
трампу ситуацію на приклад трамп
розкрито кого україни я кіно в ікону і
фінансові зубів я за не ширяє над алло
алло ви витрати 3 кран балки на ту ж
до сили 2 висотки вп посягнути типу
значок за баром zarik 2ct
живим і видних будинках а я муся він маг
води вже немає і відкрити цю критику
україна ж травня фінансів є цвинтар
через тчк і вносив іп життя скроні і ви
витрати
я думаю ще прибрані президент розумієш
чим на те ціна найсильніша і місцева
альянс у such as не історії саме йому
право роботи щось що пітера та його
чоловіків влади та зносини над чи
деталі агресивніша росія моя гасі
евакуацію отрута у його злодій це ще трампу
потрібно бага тупа смиватою яку роль
адже у в'язницю ви будуть і судді я запитав
оновити так що може і випливати на
трампа
втопити своєю уіллоу на я особливі стану
буду нічого пояс мед і трампом аллах
сонаті
я у джолі у комети намагалися бро інших сил
та всі кандидатури трампу у сфері оборони
і без паяння на жаль з хвала не моїм
адже комітетом ми поїдаємо а за прийняти а
закон про сферу національної оборони я
краще ліван і мною комітет будемо
побаченого ти знаєш іншу роль
у всьому ще пов'язана знати і анальну
оборону you in та стимулу сателіт
побачилися company ltd мейн об'єктів з
трамп сир від своїх пріоритетно до завдання
за зовнішню політику назвав боротьбу за
снамську державою та міжнародною
тероризмом та
left and actions агентств раша
адже що буде or убитий акчурин за
радість і фрації з путіним у сирі та
як би з ісламську державу ю-синема
санкції ще до Москви за право Дженні в
на слідок українського конфлікту проект
ви spouter-inn fightin oasis inn сили я
у антона лежав з очевидно, що владимир
путін набагато пак і засікав ванною
оборот безу позицію сиру та
лише прибрати без ісламську державу
наприклад поки even її волі таки
бомбарду вали памір ковану позицію
бойовики з ісламської держави знову
закупи ви пальмиру і путін не джовані
зруби проти його валу в нитку або
володимира путіна
стати ключовим портним їм на близькому
сході Петро і мати башара асада і зруби
ти вуса
щоб захистити меркава на опозицію в
сирі жадібно з їх силою не втікайте за
марокканськими
наші завдання усунення башара асада
зміщення екстремісти з ісламської
держави
піт ринку вільної сирійської армії
менших по світу кованих сил для того
щоб народ цирі з них сам ви означає і
своя мій будь не
владимир путін ви просто вас побачити
авіацію та . у зброї для того, щоб вам
побут або каріння в буває і невинних щеня
людині та дітей в алеппо та менших
регіонах серед памір кованого позиція
савич пощастило шини
і ріжу на путі на скроню вам станеться
tacwise duo sing in microsoft моєму
розумі немає трамп цитата
поважаєш що путін може буде його
союзником у сирії
бо чого на весну буду йти проти від
це трампу жила його з косою санкт ще
до Росії що ви в підсумку буде труби the
response to do is at five мері стрибати
по рибачить ще вин буде рубати і я багатий
у різьблених варіантів алленами населення
буде душа серйозну помилку
чортяка горді висоти та